I've had a chance to watch The Hobbit an
unexpected journey a few more times as
it was released on DVD I have two major
complaints first the dwarves and Bilbo
are clearly not riding ponies giving a
pony
those are full-grown horses wrapped in
shag carpet the second I think we can
all agree that the pacing the film is
way off
it is far far too short a skimpy 169
minutes of running time is devoted to
the entire first six chapters of the
book Peter Jackson totally skipped the
scene where Bilbo meets the dwarfs at
the Green Dragon Inn in Bywater the
party's sojourn in Rivendell drastically
short did wolves they've gone the trims
are unforgivable now granted this
adaptation is more leisurely than the
grotesquely truncated Lord of the Rings
films which had the nerve to devote less
than a minute of screen time to each
page of the book but still unforgivable
if Peter Jackson is already in
pre-production on The Silmarillion like
I assume I expect him to get it right
and make it 3,000 to 4,000 hours long
your move Jackson there's a lot of stuff
I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them